[音楽]
[拍手]
ほぼ緊張しないでなんか最高に楽しくなっ
ていきました
楽器も
スライドも
台本もないので
僕自身を皆さん
受け止めてください
僕自身を見守ってください
僕は
世界一明るい視覚障害者そんなキャッチ
コピーを持っています
今は
世界中の会社の
経営者の
伴奏という仕事をしています
そんな僕が今日一言
伝えたいことがあります
それは人は
言ったことでなくやったことについてくる
人は
言ったことがなくやったことについてくる
そんな
話をしましょう
脱
言語化そして
新たな経験に出会いに行く
僕は世界一明るい視覚障害者です
3歳の時に1万人に1人と言われる
網膜式と変性症という病気が上がりました
どんどんどんどん見える範囲が狭くなり
色や字や輪郭が20代前半ではわからなく
なりました
37歳の今日この今の時点では今日ここに
光る道があったと思います
大阪の八尾のゴム屋が作ってくれました
僕は今光と
色の白黒がわかる程度です
だから僕はずっと
言葉を頼りに
人とつながり
生きてきました
人生で本を
数冊しか読んだことがないでしょう
パソコンも15年以上触っていません
そして
携帯もスマホではないです
多くが言葉や言語を
求めながら生きてきました
一方
8年半経営をしてきた
NPOを卒業してから今この
経営者の伴奏という仕事をしています
経営者という人たちは
会社に買われてしまいます
そして人生にも
経営にも悩んでしています
悩んでしまいます
そんな彼らに
月に1回
会いながらつながりながら
彼らを整え
彼らが捉え直せるように
空気を入れ替えるのが僕の仕事です
電話や
オンラインを繋がら使いながら
言葉のやり取りをします
目が見えなくて
そして
経営者を言葉でつながりながら支え
そんな僕が言うんです
脱言語化
どんなこともよく上手に喋るんですよ
自分を見ててね
驚くべきくらい上手に喋るんですそれが
いつも引くらぐらいか
気持ち悪くなってきました
俺何なんだろうなと思いながら
例えばこんなことを一つ喋りましょう
今年の夏アフリカの西側にあるベナンと
いう国に行きました
ベナンは
九州と同じぐらいの人口があります
農業の現場や
学校やいろんなところに行ってきました
電気もなかなか通っていない
道路もそんなに整備されていない
光しか見えない俺にとって
そして
足元は普段ついで歩く俺にとって
結構アウェイでした
10日間ぐらい
滞在をしてとっても
楽しかったです
アフリカベナンは
フランス語ないしは現地語です
みんなで
ご飯を食べていても
フランス語や現地語が飛び交ってました
もしかしたら
慣れない日本人はその場のことをもっと
通訳してよって何のことかわからないつっ
て携帯知りだしたりするかもしれない
俺はその関係は結構楽しかったです
なんで楽しかったのかなって遅刻して考え
ました
これ俺慣れてる環境だなって
僕は日本で
会議や飲み会の中で
僕が目で見たことがない
目で感じられない
星や
虹や写真やゲームや漫画やそんな話を
みんながワイワイしてる場合によく
出くわすんです
そんな時は
空気を感じながらその場を楽しむ
これフランスこれベランの今フランス語の
状態と一緒
内容がわからなくてもその場を楽しめる
言葉で理解してるのかなと思ったけど
楽しめるんだなって思いました
2つ目
僕はこの3月から
趣味で
月に3回キックボクシングやってます
さっきも
楽屋であまりにも緊張してたのでちょっと
ボクシングの練習とあと逆立ちをしておい
たんですけどあの
魚立ちをしてもよく見えないからあの
見える姿は変わらなかったんですけどね
でこれキックボクシングを練習したんです
よ
このキックボクシングはなぜ始めたか
視覚障害を持つ仲間がね1回待機にて
おもろかったつって年末の格闘技イベント
見たらもうすぐ感化されやすいタイプなん
でそれ感化されたとキックボクシングこう
始めたんですよね
先ほど言ったように
俺の仕事ね
経営者の伴奏する仕事です
普段は
ミットを持っています
伴奏先がグローブです
みんな
愚痴や悩みや願いをバンバンぶつけてくる
んですよね
感覚的にはほぼ受け取らないでいつも
交わしてるんですけどね
で
キックボクシング俺があまりにも楽しかっ
たからそう
仲間に来てよと
でそんな仲間たちに
ミットを持ってもらいました今日は逆だぞ
と
俺のパンチを受けてみろみたいな話なわけ
ですね
みんなほとんどミッドなんか持ったこと
ない
押して皆さんよく考えてみてください
目が見えない人が
本能的にパンチしてきたら怖くないですか
でバンバン受け止めてねもらって
罪と地っていうのは
探知する側が合わせていくんですよねでは
ミッド中皆が合わせてくるわけですよねで
合わせてくれてるのに気づかず僕は上手だ
なってしまうと思うんですよね
ここで
友情が芽生えるんです
普段はこんなに喋ってんのに
月に1回伴奏しながら何年も
でもその30秒間でなんか2人でこう
繋がりながら
ミッドチしてる時
言葉はいらないなって思いました
3つ目に
先月
生まれて初めてあのスケボーしました
なんかそんなスケボーしたら今日の靴も
スケボーみたいにね空中に浮いてる靴に
なったんすけどね
そう
スケボーはまるで乗り物のようでした
目が見えない僕らは
走ったり風を感じたりそんな機会が
ちょっと少ないです
スケボーに乗ってね
乗り物みたいだなと思いました
スケボーパークに行ったりちょっと練習を
してて感じました
スケボーには音があるなって
サーフィンやスノボには音がないですだ
から説明してもらわないとわかんないです
でもスケボーは
横をすれ違ったりジャンプしたり
バーンてこけたり音がいっぱいありました
解説はいらないな
言葉はいらないなって思いました
アフリカのベランに行って
言語がわからなくても
場を楽しめた
キックボクシングの
ミッドウチのパートナーであって
心で繋がれた
スケボーやって音で楽しむことができた
言葉って何だろうなってつくづく思いまし
た
そう僕は一昨年2020年の3月末に
障害や引きこもりは不登校で
働きづらさがある人たちの
就労支援の事業所8年半経営したのバトン
タッチしました
かっこよくてバトンタッチなんだけども
ちょっと飽きちゃったんです
いろんなタグがついてきて
俺は人生でいつもね
武器を探してたんです
俺はには価値がないから
喋りが上手だとか
経営ができるとかいろんなタグを探してた
んですよそれが僕のなりたい自分でした
でもなんかなりたい自分に近づいてきて
やりきれた時に
また気持ち悪くなってきました
俺そんな奴かなみたいな
感じになってきました
バトンタッチをして1年半
ベンチャー企業の経営をしました
その時結構苦しかったです
仲間にこんな言葉をかけてごらんもらい
ました
成迫はなりたい自分とありたい自分どっち
があるのって
なりたい自分っていうのは人の期待に応え
ながら
外のパワーを借りながら
前に進む
期待に応える人生です
ありたい自分っていうのは
内なる声を聞いて
ふつふつと内発的に
何かやってみようと思う
自分から生まれてくる人生です
なりたい自分に
憧れ
目指してきました
でもなりたい自分と在りたい自分どっちが
ねんって聞かれた時に
反射的にありたい自分と
答えました
何者でもない自分でありたいなと思いまし
た
タグ付けされる自分って嫌だなと思いまし
まあ勝手だなと思いますよこんなにもなり
たかったのになったらこっちかみたいな話
ですね
そしたらまた
別の仲間が今日会場にも来てくれてます
けど
成沢君はなりたい自分になれたからあり
たい自分目指してるんじゃないかなと
言ってそうだなと思いました
ありたい自分は
言葉でを説明できない
自分の強みを捨てに行った
新たな経験に出会いに行く人生です
だから僕には
キーワードができた
初体験というキーワードです
仕事では
僕は
初体験の仕事しかやらないと言っています
ギターの塗装屋からアスベストの分析の
会社から
保育園から美容室からそうそれを屋さん
から
ゴム屋さんからそう胡蝶蘭山まで
65の業界の会社の系の伴奏をしてます
初体験の仕事をしてる気
ワクワクがたまらないです
そしてもう1個人生の方では
今年だけでも
キックボクシングサーフィン
スケボー
ドラム
捨て来年は
来年2月にねバンジージャンプやろうと
思ってるんですよ
215Mの岐阜で
バンジジャンプで
俺こうやって感じのかなって
そして来年映画も撮ろうと思っています
言語を捨てに行った俺には
新たな経験が
巡ってきました
新たな経験で人と分かり合えるテーマが
増えたんです
人と
通じ合える言葉よりも人と
経験した
分かち合った人生の方が
楽しかったです
エネルギーが出ました
言葉なんかいらねやがって思いました
今日のテーマは人は
言ったことでなくやったことについてくる
インターネットの情報や
いろんなものに僕らまみれています
僕は
目が見えない分もしかしたら
言葉にとらわれていたのかもしれません
目が見えなくて
経営の伴奏の仕事をして
言葉を
巧みに
操るような人生でした
その言葉を捨てに行ったら
いっぱいの
人と分かち合える
経験が増えました
皆さんも
新たな経験に
巡り合いに行ってください
1回だけやってみる
結果を気にしない
そんなことをしていた時にあなたの経験は
巡ってくるでしょう
そんなきっかけにこの15分がなったので
あれば
嬉しいなと思っていますありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]